I love seeing how close you guys in this
cast
I'll seem in here we are tonight we're
supporting women what does it mean to be
out here and also to have developed
these amazing friendships um it's quite
beautiful I think I'm very very proud to
be on a show with a lot of ambitious
young women who are playing ambitious
young women we're very lucky to have
such close friends I mean especially in
this industry there are so many harsh
women out there sweet gal pal by my side
is great yeah we're all very supportive
of each other - I know is so really so
different and so supportive we have to
talk about this crazy finale because you
became a serpent Archie got arrested on
account of your father on the show Mark
Consuelos what did you guys make of the
finale it was a lot you know I actually
when I read the episode before it I
thought that would be the finale because
you know Jughead comes out of the woods
and he's beaten up and then I read the
finale knows like this makes sense it's
a little bit less chaotic which I like I
feel like it ends in one place so I
think it's gonna be easy to pick up
season three yeah but the Archie story
you know and I think now they've set up
a really great like super heroes first
villain story now we really know who the
good guys are and who the bad guys are
so I think season 3 you might have a
nice comic book feel to it Archie
Andrews you're under arrest for the
murder of shadow Lake resident Cassidy
Bullock what for
Veronica knowing that her dad is the one
responsible for getting Archie arrested
what how is that gonna play out or how
do you think it gonna play out well her
finally acknowledging that her dad is
the bad guy is a long time coming but
this one I think is the the the final
blow so I'm excited to see how she
fights him in season 3 I think I think
it's about time they go head to head so
we think this is gonna make the
relationship stronger though I'd hope so
but I actually have no idea so I'm not
gonna say anything just yet
and what about your character and Tony
[Music]
I'm very excited about it I mean I've
been very vocal about how much I love
Shoni and I'm like their number one
shipper
honestly I I hope it continues in season
3 I think it's a really solid
relationship for Cheryl to have and a
support system that she needs so much
and so I think that's gonna be a really
beautiful relationship that will
continue to unfold and hopefully have a
nice momentum to it and have a little
bit more spice and then also I think the
Serpent's will also be a good community
for her as well why is her jacket red
because she's Cheryl blossom does she
need a reason absolutely not that is my
favorite answer where do you guys want
to see the show go in season 3 and are
we done with the black hood of it all I
think we're done with the black hood
yeah but I think you're in season 3 I
really want to see everyone United I
want to see lunchroom scenes again yeah
I wanna have scenes with you again oh we
don't agree friendship on the show I
want you guys singing together that
hasn't actually happened yet you're
right we are the only to happen I think
you're right some reason I just assumed
that we can you sing something on the
show that's true that's true
I danced for you and then I also have to
ask pops so Veronica now owns pops yeah
how do you want to see that play out in
season 3 why I think now it's really
exciting because she has a speakeasy to
run underneath pops and I think that'll
give her some newfound motivation to to
fight against her dad
you